and so the drama of the playoffs we get
a game three from the coliseum mike
fires
on the mound we are underway from the
coliseum what a first couple games for
anderson
that ball is hit hard on the ground
diving stabbed by lamb will he have time
no couldn't get the ball cleanly out of
his glove and it might not have mattered
anyway who's shocked another hit for tim
anderson one out in the top of the first
don't let the three for nine fool you
from abreu
that ball is hit hard again to left
field one hop and up against the wall
grossman plays the carrum anderson's
gonna stop at third jose abreu with
another bullet off his bat and he's into
second with a one-out double johan
monkatta
he rips one toward canna here and
cannon's there to make the catch so the
white sox threatened with some very loud
contact but they do not score and the
rookie gets the ball dane dunning who
made seven starts in the regular season
for the white sox we'll see how long he
lasts in this one what an assignment for
dunning you can see behind dunning the
white sox bullpen is already working two
down oh mark canna comes up
cannot rips that one into left center
field louise robert over to cut it off
la stella around the third
so the a's building a rally here in the
bottom of the first inning
and i'm going to test my theory here
with matt olson coming up rick renteria
is
coming out immediately into their
bullpen with two on and two out and it
is the rookie gerd crochet tough and bad
for olson
he goes with the breaking ball and
strikes out olson
just nasty from garrett crochet welcome
to the playoffs kid luis robert takes
the pitch from mike fires inning number
two
he drills one to left field and tosses
the bat aside my goodness where will it
land way up and out of here a titanic
home run from the rookie luis robert
the white sox have a one-nothing lead
487
feet the cookie zone for luis robert
right there thigh high and this ball is
out of here 113 miles an hour yusmero
petite used to big moments of the
playoffs is coming in this would count
as a very big moment ramon loriano who
have a word with us from his spot out of
the outfield ramone thanks for doing
this
yeah thanks for having me guys
went away well i guess the ball was
destined to find you once we started
chatting with you huh
yeah i like it we should do this more
often
yeah one out one on a's behind one to
nothing so here is robert
and that's going to be a base hit up the
middle into center field rounding third
on his way to the plate as mccann he is
going to score and the throw to second
base not in time robert advances and the
white sox have taken a two nothing lead
here in the third inning
both runs batted in by luis robert
here's mazzara
and the pits of mazzara in the air left
center field that's down for a base hit
all the way to the wall
robert's going to score easily pulling
into second is mazzara
on rbi double and it's now three nothing
white sox third inning
how big it is that robert was able to
get into scoring position
with the throw to home plate from center
field on the previous at-bat
but yeah we always feel like we can come
back always and uh win games doesn't
matter what the score is
matt olson has not had a hit in this
series this would be a good time for his
first hit base is loaded two down he's
badly need a big hit olson's not going
to get it he strikes out swinging 97
right at the knees
so hoyer out of the bullpen to get the
white sox out of the jams he's have four
hits and they've drawn two walks in the
first four innings they've had some
chances so two down for sean murphy who
walked his first time up today
that one is hit well to left field sean
murphy can watch it and we got a brand
new ball game
two-run homer for the rookie catcher
sean murphy
one swing
has changed the feel of this game big
time a really really impressive young
player 3-2 white sox were only in the
fourth inning could it be that with all
hands on deck in a winner-take-all game
that the white sox are running out of
arms they still have plenty of firepower
but they've run through a bunch
matt foster now takes over the rookie
making his playoff debut but he inherits
a bases loaded situation markana righty
against righty 3-2 white sox
way outside ball four
man
those last two pitches not anywhere
close the walk has tied the game
base is loaded two down tie game now
matt olson another shot for him
3-1
not close ball four he's walked in
another run and that's how the a's have
gone ahead
four to
three fifth inning the white sox were
ahead three nothing now they trail four
to three no mar mazzara one for two
mazara hits one on the ground and
nobody's there la stella playing as deep
as he was could not get to it monkata
steal a huge play he comes around and
scores to tie the game four to four adam
engel has had good at bats over and over
engel
took a swing popped it up la stella
loriano la stella juggles and he caught
it
what a catch by tommy lestella montas
some nervous moments there who knows if
that kicks away that might score the run
from first chad pinder is the hitter
base is loaded two down tie game bottom
five but career with the bases loaded
two for 35 not anymore into left field
past the dive of anderson
one run in the throw is
not there grendel thought he got the tag
on a two-run hit the a's go ahead six to
four and a new pitcher for the a's
joaquim soria the right-hander speed on
the bases for the white sox down two in
the eighth inning another 2-2 pitch on
the way abreu bounces it past the
pitcher simeon that's one la stella
that's two it's a double play
the a's turn it and joachim sorya one of
the biggest pitches he's made in his
long big league career go to the ninth
inning to their eighth liam hendricks is
coming in this game it is 6-4 oakland
tying run at the plate two outs in the
ninth inning and a two-ball two-strike
count hendricks trying to dig deep
here's his 2-2 mazzara takes strike
three called and a win a long time
coming for the a's franchise bob melvin
and his team earned this one what a win
today and what a series win
for the oakland athletics